when we go back extraordinarily close to
the events of the big bang when things
are super hot super dense we don't have
any of the elements that currently make
up the universe of matter as we know it
we have a state prior to the elemental
State and so people should remember that
the material world that we see around us
is made out of 114 elements some of
which are man-made not easily found in
nature so let's say a hundred and those
elements differ in the complexity of
their atomic structure you have neutrons
and protons and electrons that make up
an atom and the simpler the element is
the fewer of the neutrons and protons
and electrons are in the atomic
structure so they're more and more
complicated clumps of atomic particles
to make up the elements now they appear
in a sequence right as the universe
unfolds but before even hydrogen which
is the simplest Elemental structure
before hydrogen appears there are other
states of matter and that sequences all
the way back to the Big Bang so can you
unfold how the periodic table emerges
and then what happens before that you
know the famous poet scientist Carl
Sagan said you know we Are All Made of
Stars We're All Star stuff and it's
actually not really true we're actually
Cosmic stuff actually most of us is
water right Jordan so most of water is
hydrogen and most of that hydrogen if
not all of it was formed during these
first three minutes after the big bang
I'll say that as a shorthand for if the
period of time before which we lose
information and we become ignorant but
that period of time leaves fossils and
those fossils are the hydrogen the
helium that we see in the universe and
their Isotopes so there's really only
six or seven different things that are
made but without those things they
become the ingredients of the first
generation of stars those generation of
stars become nuclear fusion reactors
taking hydrogen nuclei and Isotopes and
fusing them together to make helium
after all Helios the name of the Sun but
helium was discovered not on Earth but
it was discovered on the sun via its
chemical Spectrum its chemical
fingerprint the first elements hydrogen
and helium are formed in the Big Bang
much more helium is formed later on in
stars then that helium makes heavier and
heavier elements and we start marching
up the periodic table to make the fill
out the rest of those hundred or so
elements
[Music]
foreign